muy buenas tardes un gran gusto estar
con ustedes el gusto es nuestro bueno
algunos gobiernos como por ejemplo por
mencionar alguno el de argentina han
solicitado al fm y que permita canjear
las deudas de los países en crisis por
financiamiento de proyectos
medioambientales es esto viable puede
colaborar el fondo monetario
internacional de esta manera quizás
y yo creo que es verdad lo que dice la
directora gerente del fondo monetario
que ese es un gran riesgo sin embargo
esto yo creo que la oferta que hacen los
argentinos es bastante oportunista en el
sentido que son proyectos que se estaban
haciendo de todas maneras en el país así
que es importante es ayudar a los
distintos países a que mejoren la
situación ambiental
no sé cuánto el fondo puede puede hacer
en términos de
entregar dinero para hacer este tipo de
operaciones porque para eso tiene que
haber un acuerdo por parte de los
principales países o las principales
potencias económicas del mundo en este
sentido cree que puede haber conflictos
quizás para algunos países un poco sea
lo adelantaban o / equilibrar sus
compromisos con el fondo y a la vez sus
compromisos medioambientales no
bueno yo creo que los compromisos
medioambientales
son muy importantes yo creo que tiene
que ver en ese sentido una actividad
o una acción que sea coordinada
yo creo nuevamente que no hay un
conflicto de largo plazo en términos de
el elemento medioambiental y el elemento
de deuda pero tiene que encontrarse un
balance muy que que puede ser muy
precario nos queda poco tiempo pero no
quiero dejar de realizar la siguiente
pregunta desde su punto de vista existe
la posibilidad quizás de enfrentar a lo
mejor un escenario en el que haya
barreras proteccionistas levantadas en
países por ejemplo de europa o en
estados unidos con el argumento de
cumplir con las recomendaciones del
acuerdo de parís
siempre es posible
espero que no yo creo que cualquier
excusa es buena para levantar barreras
proteccionistas desde la india a los
países europeos a los países
latinoamericanos y a eeuu realmente creo
que son excusas lamentables que van a
afectar la posibilidad de financiar
realmente una mejora en el clima mundial